on this episode we do it live kinda from
wine library
[Music]
this is
Carrie B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 177 of
the ask gary vee show we are at Wine
Library which is a lot of fun you'll be
catching some of that on dailyvee I
assumed Iraq in the dirty Jers in
Springfield New Jersey it's awesome to
be here
Brett good to see you India India still
snowed in or she's sick and snowed in
Bravos sick and snowed in double the
essence for India for 177 so cool really
excited sorry I've been traveling a
bunch I know for everybody that's
worried or scared dailyvee is not a
replacement for the askgaryvee show and
so I just want to settle all those
debates and I guess we should get into
it Oh first question is from shy-shy
hey Gary
it's midnight here in Israel so I
figured I use this filter my question is
how do you kill an audience on snapchat
do you have to go to Facebook and
Twitter to tell the followers there that
was basically the question yeah how do
you grow onions right on snapchat yeah
so snapchat has no natural in snapchat
app discovery which is thing with a lot
of people's heads because they're like
what the hell like where's this
suggested user list where can I search
how do I run ads like I can't grow of
course you can you grow the old way
pre-internet apps infrastructure you use
other things to grow your business I
built this business using a newspaper
and a radio and other things of that
nature so the answer is absolutely I
think he was going there I mean watch my
behavior it's not super complicated I'm
using my Twitter my email my facebook my
Instagram to drive awareness towards my
channel I'm hitting up I mean I don't
think I remember throwing this many
right hooks outside of a book ask which
is weird because I'm doing that right
now as well dropping March 8th go get it
I've asked plenty of people when they've
sent me emails like oh you've really
helped my snapchat these are
historically emails that I would reply
to and say thanks have a great day now
I'm saying hey in your next story shout
out my at Gary Vee handle I'm going in
for the ask how about the bottom of your
email signature how about your username
on Instagram go look at mine
you hack to build awareness for it you
think about billboards and print where
there's no click or permalinks or
anything of that nature no it's just
awareness drives you don't have to move
on it's got a live angle dammit I was
trying to make you move know where drew
I was very impressed with you there
d-roc we're a drink on it that was a
standoff that you won which it pisses me
off where you drive awareness to your
handle so yes any means of awareness I
mean soon I'm gonna put a sign in here
that says follow Gary on a snapchat so
yes that's the answer using other
platforms to drive awareness to get
followers from that platform but
scalable ones email signatures your
LinkedIn account look at my Instagram
profile things like that I'll ask when
you're hustling how do you spot the
difference between busy work and
valuable work you know Cal that's a
great question and honestly that's a
work in progress always to me Sam real
quick this is gonna be a real live
lesson in retail thank you
get his handle so so I think the got to
shift the brain for retail visit this is
something I've dealt with my whole life
like you know I've I don't think I've
mastered it I don't think that I I mean
I'm doing busy work even now at the
level that I'm at I'm still doing busy
work that I think is in hindsight not as
good I think experience helps you I
think over time I've learned through oh
crap I remember when I did that back in
a day don't do that again you start
understanding but I think one of the
biggest mistakes that entrepreneurs make
especially as they grow their business
or in the beginning when they're
crippled by this thought of quality work
versus just doing it you know like smart
work versus just work is when you start
judging it too much you start leaving
yourself out of opportunity for
serendipity and upside that you can't
say there's been a lot of things that on
paper may look like busywork going to
get you know just kissing babies and
shaking hands or just replying to
everybody on Twitter things that not
everybody thinks is the best scalable
use of my time that has led to enormous
upside because it wasn't obvious when
you first did it including a video ship
including 10 years ago in a month
sitting upstairs doing a video show
where everybody's like we needed you
that hour to sell wine or to reorganize
our operations why are you putting a
video on YouTube what is you to like not
it it ended up being the biggest single
biggest decision of my career up to this
point transitioning myself into a media
property and a brand from just being an
operator on his floor wasn't obvious
felt like it could have been busy work
and there's been other things that I've
done like that that have been busy work
well you know try to think of a good
example but like a million things that
we've stopped and started it didn't
become real it happens with us every day
in our team so so I think that um I
think you don't always know I think you
find out after the fact and I think to
have a long 40 to 60 year old
professional career that's successful as
long as you're learning in year 1 3 7 9
12 patterns start becoming more
self-aware by yourself understanding
your strengths and weaknesses you start
having less just busy work and more
high-impact work and that's what's
happened in my career
yes ravine my question is if we wanted
to start a subscription box service
should we buy an email list thanks Gary
Vee it's a great question I mean look at
anytime you start any business an email
list email is one of the great ways to
convert them look the answer is yes and
no yes if it's a quality list that has
open rates and click throughs and people
that are interested in your cookies of
the Month Club because it was an email
from cookie lovers but if you buy Alissa
has a million people on it and it was
part of a photography list somewhat or
just branding emails that they found
around the internet and nobody opens it
and they are into photography and you're
trying to sell them a cookie
subscription thing the answer's no
that's a very easy play if you want to
buy a list from somebody force them to
do a test for interest around what you
do force them I will not buy your list
unless you do this and it's a pre-sale
to be on the invite list for your
up-and-coming business and if you see a
bunch of people sign up for it
well now you buy now they may say well
that's like selling the milk without the
cow that whole thing you know girl done
you know like I get that but just say no
there's a million lists out there you've
got the leverage they want your money
don't forget that that's good right
that's good there's some quality content
here but there is you mean like you were
impressed that that answer produced that
kind of quality that question produced
the quality answer that was all
encompassing for business yeah and I
felt like I learned something that's why
this show exists I work for you thank
you
good by the way love these snapchat one
more time because I was talking about
how much thank you for everybody sending
snapchat videos keep them coming and use
Twitter to hit up India that was smart
hi Gary I wanna know your opinion on the
new domain extensions emojis and URLs if
you can't emoji what would it be
kinda mogees in URLs art is that
possible can you put emojis and URLs no
not yet right I think it's brilliant
I'd be so into it so into it my emoji
would be the cash with with wings
because you know most growing money's
how do you get is that real
coca-cola's was recently for marketing
here so one this is always fun for me
when I don't fully know is it a veil
like put that in poop LA right can you
do anything with it well they can't all
the big top domains only allow the
characters I mean got it so look let's
just assume that it's a loud slash it's
gonna be allowed I think it's gonna be
huge emoji as a language now period and
the story if you don't understand that
you don't understand the world like we
used to draw just because letters were
introduced doesn't mean we can't use
things now it's just communication don't
get romantic about how you communicate
worry about actually communicating in
the year that you live in there's not a
single fifty year old in America now
that hasn't sent an emoji there's 62
year old dudes that are bald as [ __ ] and
don't know anything about technology and
can't even like open an attachment that
have sent a poop emoji to their
grandchild right like let's talk about
your dad for a minute not technically
unbelievable has sent emojis yes correct
cuz that's what's happening it's crossed
over it's mainstream it's except
it's understood its pictures it's basic
baby and so I think it's huge mine would
be the dollars with wings I'm not very
hot on like domain names I think domain
names are what you make them I have
friends that are obsessed with names
I've talked about this like what is
Google or Facebook or snapchat mean it
means what you made it like Vaynerchuk
like you know like people you're so
lucky I'm like let's relax like I made
that name mean something they nerd like
like it's about what you do with it and
so I haven't really paid a lot of
attention to what's going on in that
world which is why I don't even know if
you could own a emoji calm or what
having doesn't look like comms work yet
but I'm super into it I'm all about mo
geez I even dropped the e they're like
you know like me emoji Rachelle asks
what are your thoughts on today's
Twitter executive Exodus news well I
think there's a I think that I think I
actually I asked for this question to be
on the show because I want to teach
everything about optics meaning when a
new CEO comes in and then there's this
huge Exodus a lot of times it means the
new CEO has brought in the people that
they want and they're respecting people
and letting them leave on their terms I
don't see or these people actually don't
believe in Jack's vision my intuition is
based on Twitter's track record of last
three to four years and I loved it cus
loved one of my best buds in business
and I saw him recently but results or
results meaning it didn't go good enough
for you not to be excited about the guy
who invented it to be back in place so
you might not like his personality
things of that nature but I hate when
the media is like act like everything's
so negative like the next company when I
buy a company and become a CEO of it
because that will happen to my career
and there's a exodus because Big Shot
Gary's coming let me promise you anybody
that I wanted to keep would have stayed
because I would convince them that I'm
coming to do nothing but good and maybe
three or four just wouldn't see it or
they were best buds with the former CEO
or they're just tired but please don't
get caught up in the hyperbole of like
there's some there's a new CEO we're
still within the year of that new CEO
this is a common business stuff but he
had like like this is what always
happens so you don't know if they were
forced out or they left on their own I
don't know even though I'm close to a
lot of people in
because when I read those headlines I
proved them because I'm an actual
operator I'm not confused by them I know
what real business is Jax come in he's
got a different plan some pieces fit for
that some don't some people he might
have wanted to fit for that decided they
don't fit for that it's just real life
it's not some huge conspiracy I think
you know I think that's what I think
like that's that's what it is I just I
wanted to answer this question because
I'm stunned by how many people just
accept very basic narratives when if you
live it you know the real details
underneath just like you know anything
that's in your world my world is
business you know the real I read
headlines oh my god you're like now
that's what really happened just like
we've gotten cynical to leave of absence
did you see uh did you see spotlight
okay it was about the like priest
Ellington sexual harassment oh yeah like
their official like when they were doing
bad things was they got relocated on
assignment for like or sick leave sick
leave so this Exodus maybe on strategy
get it question of the day actually
educate me tell me something that
happens in your world and how its
explained but what's really going on
could be some fun late night reading
yeah I'm going to Phoenix tonight so
hopefully Oh actually this is airing
tomorrow we're doing a little bit of a
smarter cadence on the shows doesn't
have to go out immediately you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]